Thankfully, I was able to put together a Python
script to get the current diamond price data, similar to
the original diamonds data set, from diamondse.info without too much
trouble. This data set is about ten times the size
of the 2008 diamonds data set, and features diamonds
from all over the world certified by an array of
authorities, besides just the General Logical Institute Of America, or
the GIA. You can read in this data set as
follows, but make sure you've installed the R curl and
bit tops libraries before you do. This might take a
while as a data set contains over about 500,000 cases.
The code used to obtain the data is available at
this link. Let's fit the model again to the big
data set. We'll only use GIA certified diamonds in this
log. I look only at diamonds under $10,000 because these
are the type of diamonds sold at most retailers, and
hence, the kind we care most about. By trimming the
most expensive diamonds from the data set, our model will
also be less likely to be thrown off by outliers,
and the higher variants at the high-end of price and carat.